ونحييكم من جديد الرايس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب باقين في السباق الرئاسي حتى
لو واجهتهمات جنائيه ضدها والمتعلقه
بالتحقيقات الجاريه بشان تعامله مع وثائق
البيت الابيض والتلاعب المزعوم في
انتخابات 2020 ترامب خلال المؤتمر السنوي
للمحافظين الامريكيين انه المرشح الرئاسي
الوحيد الانتخابات 2424 التي ستجرى العمل
المقبل في نوفمبر 2020
كما اكد بانه القادر على انقاذ الولايات
المتحده من الديمقراطيين ذوي النزعه
الحربيه كما قال وكذلك المتعصبين
والاغبياء في الحزب الجمهوري وفق قول
ترامب واضاف ترامب ان ناخبين الامريكيين
سائموا من العلاقات السياسيه المتجذره في
الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي ومن المصالح
الخاصه ومن السياسيين المحبين للصين
وانصار الحروب الخليجيه التي لا نهايه لها
وبعد تعبيره عن رفضها المساعده الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا قالت ترامب ان العالم سيشهد
حربا عالميه ثالثه اذا لم يحدث شيء بسرعه
مضيفا انه المرشح الوحيد الذي يمكنه ان
يقطع هذا الوعد
ترامب يتعهد بمواصله السباق الرئاسي 2004
ويتوعد الديمقراطيين بالهزيمه
دونالد ترامب رئيس الامريكي السابق معكم
وبجانب سنخدم الدوله العميقه وسنطرد دعاه
الحرب وسنطرد العولمه ونطرد الشيوعيين
وسوف نتخلص من الطبقه السياسيه التي تكره
بلادنا
ترامب حصل على المركز الاول في كل
استطلاعات الراي السابقه لسيفاك
متقدما على حاكم فلوريد روندي سانتوس وهو
على الارجح اقرب منافسين
ومتقدما كذلك على رجل الاعمال بيري جونسون
الذي اعلن ترشحه للبيت الابيض هذا الاسبوع
ترامب اطلق محاولته للترشح للبيت الابيض
لعام 2024 في نوفمبر الماضي
حمله ترامب تجري وسط تحقيق مستمر من قبل
وزاره العدل حول ما اذا كان قد ازال ما
يقرب من ثلاثه الاف وثيقه من البيت الابيض
وتلاعب بنتائج انتخابات 2020
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
الدكتور اطنان غريب الاستاذ في العلاقه
الدوليه اهلا بك ومن نورلاندو توم حرب
رايس وتحالف الامريكيه شرق اوسطيه
للديمقراطيه اهلا بكم ضيوفي اسمحوا لي ان
ابدا مع الدكتور رائد في الواقع هذه
التصريحات التراب التصريحات التي يهاجم
فيها وينتقد فيها ليست غريبه تابعناها
وناقشناها من قبل ولكن هذه المره ترامب
ضغط على زر جدا حساس في هذه المرحله وهو
الحرب الاوكرانيه وقال انه ان استمرت هذه
الحرب فنحن داخلون على حرب عالميه ثالثه
وانا الوحيد القادر على ايقاف هذه الحرب
العالميه وهنا يطرح السؤال من من مصلحته
من بعد هذا التصريح فوز ترامب او من يخشى
ذلك
تحياتي لك
من الواضح ان الرئيس السابق يواجه
حمله قويه ضده وهذه الحمله تاتي من طبعا
من الديمقراطيين ولكنها ايضا تاتي من
القيادات في الحزب الجمهوري وخاصه
في مجلس الشيوخ وفي المؤسسه
الجمهوريه هؤلاء لا يريدوا
من ترامب ان يرشح مره ثانيه واذا رشح نفسه
يرغبون في هزيمته لانهم يعتقدون انه
يهددهم ويهدد المؤسسه اجمالا فهتحدث في
حديثه امام احدى المنظمات المحافظه يوم
امس
بانه هو سيحارب الدوله العميقه هو كما
تفضلتي الذي سيمنع الحرب العالميه الثالثه
وانه لو كان في الرئاسه لما كانت هذه
الحرب ستحدث
اعتقد اولا من ناحيه هو فعلا نجح في ابعاد
الولايات المتحده الحروب ولكن هل كان لديه
القدره ستكون لديه القدره عند فعلا على
وقف هذه الحرب لان المؤسسه الامريكيه
اجمالا ترغب في شن هذه الطرب وتعتقد انها
تشكل تهديد للموقع القيادي للولايات
المتحده ولكن فعلا اذا كان هناك شخص مسؤول
على هذا المستوى يمكن له ان يؤثر فهو
من اين لترامب كل هذه الثقه اولا بانه
القادر على ايقاف هذه الحرب ومن قبل ذلك
بانه هو المرشح الاساسي للابرز الاهم
للانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه كيف يمكنه ان
تكون له كل هذه الثقه وهو اساسا ينتقد
حزبه ينتقد جمهوريين بارزين واسماء كبيره
اولا مرحبا لك
الكرام هلا طبعا كان له خبره على اربع
سنوات قاد البلد بجديه معظم كان هنالك
شكوك في السياسات الخارجيه وضع حدا لها
قضى على داعش
التوتر الذي كان حاصل بين كريه الشماليه
والمجتمع الدولي وضع حدا له ونعرف بان
الروسيه بالالف 2014 احتلت مدينه الكرم
وبفتره عهده لم تحتل ولم تستفز اي دوله في
ذلك المنطقه
وعلمنا كيف تعاطى مع بشار الاسد وحتى مع
فنزويلا يعني وضع حدا للحروب والماسات
الدوليه وكان زاهدا ولكن استاذه تهم وقتها
كان يقف ورائها الحزب الجمهوري كذلك بكل
اسمائه حتى وان كانت هناك اختلافات ولكن
الحزب كان قائم هذا الحزب نفسه لم يشهد
انقسامات كما شاهدها في الفتره الفائته
والترامب كانت له يد في ذلك
لا لا بالعكس يعني نحن نتذكر عندما ترشح
بال 2015 كان هنالك انتقادات عديده من
الحزب الجمهوري التقليدي وكان 16 اكثر كان
21 مرشح ضدها وتنازلوا الى 16 وبعدين كان
هو المرشح الرسمي لان كان هو مبدع
بالسياسه بورقه العمل السياسيه الداخليه
وضع مشاريع لمصلحه امريكا الداخليه
والخارجيه واليوم نحن نرح في كل المرشحين
في الحزب الجمهوري لان سنسمع منهم ربما
مشاريع لمصلحه الحزب الجمهوري ولمصلحه
امريكا اولا واذا كان من حظهم ونصيبهم انه
طبعا
انه الترقص الحزب الجمهوري اهلا وسهلا بهم
واذا لا فاذا كان الرئيس ترامب هو المرشح
الذي سيكسب معظم الاصوات للحزب الجمهوري
فسيتحدى الديمقراطيين ولكن خطابه نهار امس
كان بامتياز ووضع ثلاث نقاط اساسيه النقطه
الاولى الذي وضعها انه معاقبه الصين لانه
يعتبر بان الصين هي وراء
الكورونا ويجب معاقبتها ولا اي شخصيه
امريكيه حتى الان قالت سنعاقب الصين وحتى
بالحزب الجمهوري اذا كان
الحاكم ولايه فلونتس سيترشح لم نعرف بعد
اذا سيعاقب الصين وكيف يعاقب الصين طبعا
بغرمات ماليه على الصين نقطه لانه بيقولوا
فاتحين الحدود الامريكيه مع المكسيك لانه
نحن بحاجه الى شعب اكثر هو قال سندعم
التناسل في الولايات المتحده وهذا نقطه
جديده لم احد بعد يطرحها والنقطه الثالثه
هي القفزه النوعيه القفزه النوعيه بناء
على اراضي حكوميه لانه في ولايات نسبه 60
70% هي تمتلك
الدوله تمتلك هذه الاراضي سيقوم ببناء
جديده في هذه المناطق ومع سيارات تطوير
السيارات التي ستصبح الطائرات بنفس الوقت
وكل الملفات التي تمكن من ادارتها حضرتك
مدافع شرس عن ترامب وهذا نعلم وهو لكن سقط
ملف مهم وهو القضايا الجنائيه ضده ويطرح
هنا سؤال ما مدى اهميه هذه القضايا خاصه
وان ثبتت عليه الاتهامات دكتور ادمان هل
تعتقد بان هذه القضايا الجنائيه قد تعرق
الوصول الى البيت الابيض وقد تعرقل حتى
امكانيه ان يلتف ما تبقى من الحزب حوله
فعلا الرئيس ترامب سيواجه تحديات كبيره
بسبب هذه القضايا خاصه اذا وجهت اليهم من
وهو المدعي العام الان الذي يركز على هذه
القضايا
اتهامات او ادينا من قبل هيئه المحلفين
الكبرى التي يتراسها وهناك اسئله حول ما
اذا كانت فعلا وزاره العدل ستقوم بادانته
ام لا وطبعا ولكن هذه ستضع عقبات امام
الرئيس ترامب في نفس الوقت فان ايضا ترامب
لديه بعض يعني يمكن هو ان يعرقل ايضا عمل
المدعي العام كيف اولا هو لا يزال يقول
بان له هو لديه الحصانه كرئيس سابق بالا
يتم
مطالبته او اجباره على تقديم شهادته
ويطالب ايضا بمعار
ويعارض قيام نائب الرئيس بانسبي تقديم
شهادته وهذه ما يطلبها ايضا المدعي العام
وبانسي يطالب ذلك كيف يقول بانه هو لم يكن
فقط نائب الرئيس بل كان ايضا رئيس مجلس
الشيوخ وبالتالي فانه ليس هناك حق
للمدعي العام بان يجبره على الادلاء
بشهادته وهنا نقطه مثيره ان بدانا على
الرغم الخلافات بين بانس وبين ترامب
فانهما على الاقل على هذا الموضوع الموضوع
يتفقان معا ولكن السؤال هل المحكمه ستحكم
لترامب وتمنحه الحصانه اعتقد انه حتى لو
لم يتم ذلك فان ترامب والجمهوريين ومحامور
على الاقل سيقوم برفع وليس فقط امام
المحاكم البدائيه والمحاكم الاستثنائيه
وربما ايصالها الى البيت الابيض هذا يعني
بان القضيه ستكون خلال مرحله اما
الانتخابات التمهيديه او الانتخابات
الرئيسيه
توجهتهم للديمقراطيين بانهم يتلاعبوا
بهذه القضيه لاغراض انتخابيه ويقومون
بتسييس وزاره العدل وبالتالي بينما
نعم صحيح
تحدثت عن تصريحات الديمقراطيين ولكن هناك
كذلك تصريحات ممن كانوا مساندين جدا
للتراب نتحدث اليوم سيد توم عن تصريحات
وزير الخارجيه السابق واليوم كانت لها
تصريحات ملفته تتحدث فيها عن وجوب ان تكون
هناك وجوه جديده ان تتقدم ان تقود
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الاعلام
الامريكي قراها على انه يتوجه لتراب خاصه
وان على عكس
لم يقدم ترشحه بطريقه واضحه ما رايك
باختصار انت كرمت
بالقضاء القضاء القضاء
بالطعام الدكتور ادمون القضاء يعني
الامريكان البرلسيه ينظر انه لماذا محاكمه
رئيس كان رئيس الولايات المتحده واخذ
اوراق فيها سريه
ونائب الرئيس كان وكان سنه هو بايدن من
السبعينات ياخذ اوراق سريه ولم يعاقب يعني
صار في عنا نوعان من القضاء وهذا مرفوض
اما بالنسبه
ان انتخابات لمجلس النواب ولهذا للتجديد
وافكار جديده ولكن بالنتيجه بالانتخابات
التمهيديه الشعب يقرر هو على كل تصريحات
ستبقى دائما المتابعه اعذروني وسامحوني
انتهى تماما توقيت هذه الحلقه دكتور أطمان
غريب شكرا لك وكذلك استاذ توم حرب شكرا
جزيلا لكما
السلام عليكم